Cái quét của chính phủ yêu cầu các cấp, ngành địa phương, tập trung chỉ đạo điều hành thử
gệm một tiêu tăng trưởng rồi đe P cả nước năm 2020, phần đầu từ
mười phần trọng trở lên, gặn rồi dứ vấn ordent kinh tế vi mô, kìm
sói lạ phát và bảo đam các cân đổi lớn, theo đò các tình thành phố được
giao gà sói, xây dựng kịch bản tăng trưởng rồi đe P theo từng quyết, chia theo
bà khu của kinh tế, có bộ ngành cú phà có kích bản giân, cho tình lĩnh vực
các bảo cáo gửi mộ tài chính xong tháng 2, nề tổng hợp theo dõi, theo dõi
theo nghị quét, chính phủ sẽ định yêu cầu đổi mỗi tư ruy, quả chỉ và phân bộ mũ lực
kết hợp với giải pháp nhằm chuyện đổi mũ hình tạo trưởng, khoa công nghệ
lời mời sáng tạo và chuyện đổi số được xác định là độc lực chính, cùng với các thành phần kinh tế để tạo
một lực cho phát triển. chính phủ nhấn mạnh, việc sết kỳ lọt kỳ cương, khoan thiện thề chè gặn
với tăng phần kết phân quyền, nề cáo chân nghiệm về đường đầu trong tham nhúng laf ý, bên cạnh đó có bộ ngành cân tiếp tục
các giảm phụ tục, cải thiện mũ chực kỳ lọi và nề mạnh đầu tư hạt tâm trên lược, miêu giao thông và nâng lượng.